8 news now breaking news alert
and breaking now an fbi investigation
underway up in the northwest valley
after an agent was involved in a
shooting good evening to you thank you
for joining us on this thursday at five
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
this is all happening near the 215 and
anne road we're told there's been a
barricade situation unfolding there for
quite some time now we are waiting for
an update directly from the fbi but
let's check in with joe mohler with what
we know right now
brian denise we know that one fbi agent
did end up shooting a person here and
that person is injured i'll give you a
live look here at the investigation like
you mentioned we're still waiting for an
update from the fbi here at hualapai and
but you're taking a look at anne it is
still closed for this investigation the
next stop sign there is roughing and
that is where the home
that was with the barricade situation
unfolded was at a home there on roughly
now these streets have been closed for
several hours we also have some video
from this afternoon a few hours ago we
did learn of this barricade situation
unfolding at that home a metro
helicopter was out here circling the
area and metro did close down several
streets around three o'clock we heard a
loud boom and then that helicopter left
now in a tweet fbi las vegas confirmed
the shooting and that one subject was
wounded now we are still waiting to get
details about why exactly the fbi was
called out to this investigation now
back out here live you're taking another
look at ann and ruff and you can see
just how many metro units and also fbi
patrol cars are out here on on and here
which is closed again we are at
hualapine and we're still waiting for an
update from fbi they told us to
everybody about an hour ago to come to
this intersection for an update so as
soon as we learn more information we'll
be sure to pass it on hopefully we do
learn some more information about why
exactly fbi was called out here in the
first place reporting live joe mohler
live local now